two
welcome welcome everybody we are off the
rails today and actually
we've got a special episode go ahead
clap you can clap yeah don't be shy
don't be humble thank you shredder today
is something special we've been planning
for a while mr
verified
what is mr verified you ask it's our own
version of uh miss universe featuring
all the guys
the categories
are
we're going to ask questions
we're going to test them on their style
and we're going to check on their hidden
talents we're going to have a live
vote you can the link's going to be in
the description we're going to unveil it
the winner on friday and the win why is
it called mr verified
well the guy that got let's talk a
little bit the guy's been arguing
backstage quite a bit about trying to
get verified
being verified is very important to some
of them um
and
right am i right uh mostly zach yeah
mostly to zach yeah yeah well i i've
i've experienced a great deal of people
actually
stealing [ __ ] off my instagram page like
what just some videos of me playing
guitar pretending to be me and
stuff like that
and it's just kind of like [ __ ] i need
that blue checky my dude we need that
blue check needs that blue check but
let's be honest any of these guys would
be happy to have a blue check you right
oh but of course i actually don't i i
hate the check mark thing
i don't exist on social media i don't
want a blue check yeah dan says that but
i mean i've been saying it consistently
for like the last month that we've been
talking about in this episode
dan's play is the reverse psychology
play where he acts like he doesn't care
and he does a whole anti this isn't just
for the show though i was i didn't even
want to do this episode
you're playing right into the trap you
forced me to do this
i can't quite i'm not god i can't work
you're my boss what am i gonna do
completely refuse come on i said i
didn't want i said yeah i said do a b
ian and zach and i could you guys
run it from behind not at all this is a
lot of fun are you i mean come on
this month well regardless i wouldn't
buy it but the reason i do is dan is
like legit free of want anything like
even free [ __ ] we get you see that how
that guy shovels down chips
well tell me he's free of one that's the
exception that was a whole thing in the
sketch last week was uh that was what
got me to
break my zen meditation was though
well regardless um very excited
to present uh mr verified coming up in a
little bit later here
and um so the winner of mr verified i
will be using my considerable resources
which basically consists of writing just
an email to some
uh social media reps that i'm in contact
with for twitter so just to clarify it's
not a guarantee right oh absolutely i
can't guarantee anything the promise is
you will write a single email i'll take
it exactly so i will write an email
to the instagram uh tick talk and
twitter social reps that i have
and i'll say hello dear xxx this person
is a huge is massive deserving legendary
please uh check eat them up i guess
that's all i can do to piss off the
instagram god i mean i mean i can't of
course i can't guarantee it i don't work
for instagram we just want protection
from the instagram gods yeah i'm going
to protect your algorithms for being
just watching my algorithms get crushed
but mostly it's the title i mean let's
be honest it's the blue check email yeah
i'll be honest yeah i want it and the
only reason i really want it is just to
flex some people back home that's it
that's good back home huh back home here
how many people check it out back there
yeah foot soldiers love you guys but
whatever they know me but back home if
they got to see the blue check
yeah now as you're saying in la more
people are checked out everybody's
checked out yeah i i kind of agree with
that at home in detroit not so many
checks not so many checks there's some
people in high school that piss off a
lot if i had one so oh
that's that's good yeah that'd be pretty
cool but more importantly zach doesn't
want those fake accounts you know i'm
sure there's ton hordes of them i can't
show you it's getting out of hand that's
the big thing i'm sure there's hordes of
uh it happened yeah and i feel bad
because people are like is it the zack
lewis with
four followers okay or the one with
fifty thousand right you can't tell
anything nowadays you know yeah and i
mean it's you playing guitar so how much
how damaging can it really be to steal
your content i mean it it it feels it's
not like they can plaster their own face
on it and i mean you can do anything now
with photoshop sure fair enough
ian how are you you feeling motivated
you feeling interested or do you want
the title i mean you know it's uh
sure it's a good bonus there's a guy
with my name who's a real estate
developer and he's not verified so i
want to flex on that i'm sending him a
message instantly
that's important yeah that is important
so dan is the only one who is rising
above but i appreciate your honesty ian
how many times have you tried to get
verified zach
good question uh
one two three four
five or six
and and and what do they tell you uh
when they reject you well their their
qualifications are you need like a um
you need print like a printed article
about you oh um that's gonna be a tough
one yeah um but now there's a feature
where you can add links
to um try and get verified so um
it just doesn't work they're like uh
sorry it's not important maybe we should
hold maybe what i can do then is the
winner i'll i'll pay someone to write an
article about them
and we just put it in some dumb spam
site but it's interesting because
there's some people that are verified on
instagram or twitter well hold on this
is perfect i'll pay a writer
to make the an article about the winner
of mr verified
and then we can post it on some weird
site map spam black hat seo crap or
whatever i i don't know the specifics
but that that's one of the uh
qualifications alrighty there you go the
the ante's been up even further
the winner gets an article
exciting stuff here guys really fun well
today's episode is sponsored by kraken
upstart expressvpn and hbo max we love
our sponsors guys don't we
that makes it all possible you know who
i love even more than my sponsors i hate
to say it but i got to my wife
i know it's hard to believe
i know it's hard to believe
but i do love her more than our sponsors
much more in fact
speaking of my wife teddy fresh thursday
10 a.m
new collection is just i gotta say this
is one of the finest
she's ever put out look at this tie-dye
shirt
hand brushed
water brushed tie-dye i have never seen
a shirt like this in all my life
look at the details
you know cropped
women's patchwork
that's hot another colorway
oh that's hot don't touch me cat uh
i forget the name
that's the old one
don't worry about that
yeah so if you guys are interested uh
when this comes out in the morning
teddy fresh you know what it is check
out our new collection thank you thank
you peace and love
oh one other uh update here so obviously
you guys heard the tragic news that
families has come to its
natural conclusion and
uh we love our my parents and we wish
them well but we must move on we must
press on h3tv is now going to be
happening live on youtube to consolidate
the forces i still want to collaborate
with people on twitch bring them over
while we're all live i think that
that'll be awesome
but right now we are planning next week
to start doing monday and tuesday
h3 tv live we're really excited because
we've been working on the format
and it's going to be like uh
interactive
uh submissions
taking questions reacting to stuff
we've got a really great system for
screening calls and suggestions now
since our gecko episode
and um
we're going to implement that system and
i think i'm really excited actually i
think it's going to be a really fun time
so
monday tuesday
and in the meantime we're working on
finalizing the details for
the new host
exciting news to come in
and join me on another
kind of
you know
format with another person so that's
exciting we're all excited
looking forward always looking forward
so join us on monday and tuesday for
h3tv
listen james charles guys you know i
hate to keep i keep i hit
i hate to beat a dead horse but this is
funny man yeah really sad
james charles
liked this tweet
why is every person over the age of 18
convinced that the only way to have fun
is to drink or get high
[Music]
what do you know about anything over of
people over the age of 18
here was a good response that is so true
love how james charles liked this when
it said over the age of 18 like he would
actually know what people do over 18 do
oh my god this is the t it's a little
bit of a sussy tweet to like
you see the power of that blue checky
this guy's getting away with
he's getting away don't touch a lot you
can't keep getting away with this
yeah why are all people over the hdt age
of 18 convinced that the only way to
have fun is to drink or get high i just
want to have good clean fun with james
charles
and that's why he's interested in people
under 18
because they know how to have fun i
wonder if he'd go to the mall with him
going to the mall is a good way to have
fun if you're under 18. run into a b
there hopefully
yeah i mean
uh james is interested in people under
18 who have interest like going to the
playground
sister snatched well i'm just curious
what people under 18 do they have fun um
he plays fortnite i know that
minecraft so
shout out to james
one other top of the show one rudy
giuliani
the ghoul himself
this guy if he needs any more
supporting evidence that he's the one of
the fallest human beings on earth
i mean how many times does rudy
embarrass himself outside the
the uh
the porn shop the porn shop you know he
did an interview where he was literally
dripping from his forehead like zorg
believed from the fifth element of
bleeding squidding from his head
and now here he is the former mayor
of new york city america's mayor the
president's personal lawyer
is caught
in an airport cafe shaving
what
should i play
yeah here he is shaving
in a [ __ ] airport cafe you
absolute demon
you freaked
the me is using what what is this he's
using like
using water from the table to lube it up
or something
it looks like at the very end of the
video he reaches over to grab a chunk of
food or something
have you no shame at all sir and it's a
sexual dance
like this is something i expect to see
in walmart
but let alone rudy giuliani the former
pr
mayor of new york
the president former president's
personal attorney to do this in public
too i mean have you no shame sir going
for a slice of bread right afterwards
all right i was right he is going to eat
that [ __ ] is covered in your [ __ ]
stubble dude like it's going all over
the place it's definitely on whatever it
is that he's supposed to put in his
mouth i just this guy is a walking l
machine i mean this guy
i i'm blown away here here's michael
rappaport's commentary which which was
apt so i'll play that for you with his
original commentary
take it away michael
says it better than i could look at this
[ __ ] live from jfk
sunday
in jfk look at rooney giuliani former
mayor of new york you nasty filthy
sloppy disgusting filthy [ __ ] animal
i'm showing it again show it again
shaving your
shaving yourself in public
you [ __ ] pig you should be ashamed of
yourself lock him up you [ __ ] dog you
yeah michael certainly has a way with
words and i think he nailed it right on
the head i mean think we should lock him
up
it's unbelievable
disgusting
this guy says that the election was
stolen and the man can't even [ __ ]
am i supposed to take the word of a man
who shaves in an airport cafe on
anything i mean again like this is
disgusting but when we've already
witnessed him just just oozing
[ __ ] black sludge
yeah from his skull it's like where do
you even go from there i mean the guy is
just a [ __ ] grotesque human being
dude i swear to god and i i'm sure many
of you remember this movie it's one of
my favorites
zorg you're talking about fifth element
yeah that is a wedding black
ooh
and then here there's even a rudy
giuliani meme without me even asking
well yeah it's definitely
it's spot-on comparison here's literally
what happened
god damn anal sex yes exactly
so shout out
uh one other thing i wanted to get to
you know snitch star keemstar whatever
you want to call him
karen star some have called him
i'm not here to criticize him i'm only
here to report the news because i would
never
harass or criticize this man
you know and and yes i and yes he is
writing emails constantly to youtube
and so i don't want to you know i don't
want to say anything negative about him
because he's going to report it to
youtube
so i'm just i'm simply going to report
on the news and this is certainly
newsworthy this is something that a lot
of people are talking about what the
[ __ ] is this
this is snitch star outside triller
headquarters because they won't want to
[ __ ] explain this [ __ ] to me
yeah he's trolling you
but this is a photo of someone else
they're like oh kim's in the back
randomly
oh he he restored he restored it yeah
so frustrated you think he's over
knarking on on me to kavanaugh
bro i mean he
he's the guy that's got the dossier on
everything apparently what was he um
what do you think gaby you get in the
mind i've i felt like he was from the
beginning
i said that
well what's funny is you constantly see
kavanaugh
like he pinned a story about like
me when i got in trouble for saying
something
and um they mentioned stuff like that
too and their latest complaint that
seemed completely out of nowhere and
someone has to be informing of this
stuff and here you have him at triller
hq
it's the same person that sends it yeah
he does this he goes out of his way to
do it yeah who was it recently uh it was
uh what you were feuding with what's her
name nikita yeah oh and david dobrik too
right right like basically anybody that
you get into [ __ ] with he's immediately
in their dms trying to give him you know
giving him the folder from his desktop
bro some some people accuse me of being
obsessed with keemstar
bro this man there's no comparison i
hate keemstar
no well he said it not me
for the record i didn't say that
box me [ __ ]
didn't say that either
yeah big element yeah i remember nikita
like i was beefing with her because i
was like just you know i was just
fighting with tricia you were defending
trisha yeah i mean i was i was going to
bat for her
and she started tweeting out all the
classics and then we were all like oh
it's definitely keemstar and you know he
admitted to it i think
keemstar shut up
didn't say that
wasn't me
so that's interesting it's like snitch
star
is really an app name when you think
about it
damn and and to think that him restoring
this is interesting and not outing
himself for being a snitch
well he thinks snitching's okay as long
as it's public
so maybe this is his way of justifying
it just like he said oh i told on yeah i
told on ethan i tagged susan but it was
public
i don't think he actually thinks that
because he
i think he's just doing somersaults to
justify
right
um anyway there's some there's actually
just this is kind of just our editorial
take on this
um
nobody likes a tattletail that's
keemstar's face on a child
yes oh yes i'm bald
yes i would like
to talk to the manager
that is a reference to karen starr some
call him cairnstar
not me of course
some
[Music]
stay snitching and keep bitching that's
him with uh takashi 69 another famous
snitch
you know
[Music]
and i can't say i understand this one
here what is this that's the famous
karen in the park
oh wow i'm not familiar with this
photo so people will get this yeah very
popular karen meme okay just a sweet
family so he's calling susan presumably
yes yeah
susie potter and the ball didn't snitch
[Music]
that would be susan waginski
who he tagged on twitter
uh
susan wojcinski and the baldon snitch
and keemstar is the golden snitch from
harry potter
love that
of course i'd never
love kim
[Music]
i wish the best for him
oh where's the honor what's the
honorable mention meme is it in here and
i missed it
uh
that was the one with the photoshop
where you photoshopped his girlfriend
out
uh that the
who what it was in this folder
because it's too much how is it too much
it's fantastic
i'm busted how is that too much it's not
it's just him in a pool
i have been caught like literally don't
care about the girlfriend or the breakup
i just love him in the pool
add it back please i'm begging you or
put it in discord
yeah kim could send it
thank you
good luck ethan
yeah keemstar's actually been you know
taking applications for new
girlfriends
which is you know
keemstar [ __ ]
what 40 min 40 year old men do when
they're looking for you know
girlfriend
thank you cameron this was um
[Music]
yeah i was just this picture
well i don't see what's what's so bad
about this photo
yeah i don't see what's wrong with this
one i mean it's a man and a jersey and a
hat and a pool like that's pretty normal
there was something photoshopped out of
it but i don't remember what
[Laughter]
and you know there was a big there was
some big keemstar news actually it's
been widely reported i'm gonna submit it
without commentary
of course
because i don't want to harass keemstar
i would never
never
too
mad i posted this
uh let's watch yeah keemstar made an
appearance on aiden ross's stream very
popular twitch we've talked about a few
times
uh here is keemstar's appearance
can turn it up a little bit crypto [ __ ]
hey get his ass and run out
what's up buddy how you doing hey how
are we doing though real good you good i
just did a podcast with tana mojo it was
so raw so really epic
[Music]
gemini
jesus
i think you should box here's why
you have natural energy they see it in
the stream
right you need that like you have
natural energy
you guys you mean holy energy
like some cold like [ __ ] no emotions
like killer energy about you i'm 39
she's 20. so he came at me like
whatever and he was like saying that i
had like a little dick my dick didn't
work as [ __ ] and he got trouble with
youtube
yeah so here's keemstar in a room of
like
people
in a social setting
he's on stream and what does he do he
brings me up
no one there gives a [ __ ] it's like shut
up he goes ethan said my peepee's small
and i'm dating a 20-year-old
and then i think the natural response
that most of them are have and then he
goes and then he got in trouble with
youtube it's like i think the natural
response is like first of all
like
why do you care that he just made a
stupid joke
and why are you celebrating they got
banned on youtube some like a little
snitch
also for most of the people in that room
other than aidan probably who's ethan
what are you talking about who are you
they have no yeah he thinks that
everybody's following our beef in the
whole world
again i refuse that we have beef of any
kind i think shut up he's just obsessed
with the story
but anyway um
yeah people don't care and they are
confused and uh it's like i snitched to
youtube and he got in trouble and he
said i had a little peepee and i'm
dating a 20 year old
it's like dude
bad vibes
on the fence you see what do you think
about that look at this
no what's even worse is every time
he legitimately went on his show this
[ __ ] wanted a show he said it
was on anti-depressants and the side
effects were that he didn't have feeling
in his dick
projection
again it's like
shut up why are you talking about
that my my phallus doesn't have
is as reduced sensitivity do you think
really
that these dudes want to hear that and
furthermore
i don't think that it's the diss you
think it is
being like this dude selling
antidepressants what a loser
like i really don't think that's that
especially you're trying to reform
yourself right
as the new enlightened
mental health advocate
i don't think making fun of somebody for
taking antidepressants is necessarily a
good look
it's a very common side effect keemstar
it's like a romeo julia
this is such a disaster for him
like dude you came on you're talking
about another dude's
sensitivity and his penis
team star [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] dude
bro so weird
and let's be honest if you're gonna
accuse anyone of harassment or going
below the belt i think attack i mean
making fun of me for being on
antidepressants and having side effects
is not really that valid not really that
cool of a commentary not that it offends
me and not that i'm complaining to mommy
susan
just saying
he's trying to put that on me
cool dude he literally bounced
the lie detector the hood [ __ ] lie
detected the text
[Applause]
so something funny happened
and then keemstar
overreacts so hard
and kills
dude
you know i think i was watching a video
of a guy he had a really good
observation he's like this is what
happens when you put keemstar in a
natural setting where
um
you're not being louded as some cool
dude by a bunch of 12 year olds who who
can ratio people on twitter
like this is what real life is like
great
[Music]
and you know that's about all i have to
say about keemstar who you know
i think's a great guy
with love and adoration
the ultimate entertainer
the best in class he's the best at what
he does folks
keemstar
there's actually one other absolutely
unbelievable story that i feel like i
have to talk about before we get into it
the guy from infowars
who made a whole story attacking me in
fact he even went as freakishly low as
to accuse me of being a p-word
because i posted a picture of my newborn
baby's butt on instagram listen to this
by the way this is the guy that shows
the entire world uh pictures uh
loves to show people pictures of his
baby's butt
uh not i wouldn't be into that he's into
that but that's fine
he's such a weirdo dude anyways
about how i was saying i think people
should get vaccinated was this really
related to the crowd or thing or was it
something else no
another another time that a bunch of
right-wing weirdos got mad at you it's
amazing that just saying i think people
should get vaccinated very upsetting is
enough to rile
all the hornet's nests but anyway this
guy did like a whole 10-minute hit piece
on me saying that
did he say about me
horrible things and then he ended it up
with saying you know i like individuals
ethan klein he gets to exist on youtube
and he gets to exist on facebook
and he knows in order to be able to do
that he has to promote the big
government he has to promote a big lie
that's what i'm doing so that he can
have his
videos on youtube he says
hey no vaccine passport if you want to
be on youtube you have to promote
vaccines it's not fascism you whiny f
words right this was why we are trying
to prevent people from dying oh please
oh please why does he not oh please
number one so first they insult yeah i
found that i found that to be altered
and ultimately irony
is that for all the vile [ __ ] they say
uh
the f word is is is a
that's a lie too far yeah yeah you hide
their inferior intellect
then they give you their very virtue
signal anyway this was a thing that
happened
well the new the update with this guy is
fantastic
uh let me just roll this clip
and we'll take it from there
this was from a few days ago it happened
during a live broadcast of infowars
he got a call from his lawyer with some
bad news the deal
ladies and gentlemen
a couple hours ago
i was informed by my attorney
that there is a warrant out for my
arrest tragic with allegations
involving january 6th
you don't say and i will have to turn
myself in no
monday morning
[Music]
so sad there's a lot of questions
some i have answers to some i don't
i'm not gonna be getting into more of
this today on the air
good idea
and
suck in a day
declaring innocence of these charges
because i am and so there's some other
stuff going on too
but uh that's the deal
good luck so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
comment any further on this i'm not
gonna take any questions on this today
but again i was informed by my lawyer
that there's a warrant out for my arrest
right now and that i have to turn myself
in by
monday morning
bummer
such a bomber
why do good things hap why do bad things
happen to good people
yeah he doesn't he's going to declare
innocence but good luck here's the
complaint let's see let's just go to the
exhibits where they show photos here's
[ __ ]
be a part of history fight for trump
here's [ __ ]
that's not that incriminating by itself
but this is
storming the capital
wait storming the capital
hello
i never sucked any ding-dongs
right
storming the capital
this was put together by the fbi
presumably
rough times dude rough times man
can i just saying that whole clip he was
talking like owen wilson in that marvel
clip
he was i don't know anything further
this is the first time for me
being arrested by the fbi
this is the first time for me being out
being held accountable
this is the first time for me
when keeping it real goes wrong hey
and can you believe i'm still walking
the street
while posting pictures of my newborn
babies butt once on instagram
for shame there's no justice in this
world is there
well with all that being said let's
throw it to a commercial break and when
we come back let's get in to mr verified
time to take a short break
hey guys if you're interested in
investing in crypto currencies but
aren't sure where to get started
check out our friends kraken app
with kraken you can buy and sell over 50
of the most popular cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin
dogecoin ethereum on the go 24 7 it's
super easy to get started all you got to
do is download the app create your
account and you'll be investing in
minutes it's one of the coolest things
about buying crypto through kraken is
that you don't need a lot of money to
try it so even if you want to buy some
bitcoin you know that's probably
somewhere around 40 000 you can buy
for as little as ten dollars just to get
your feet wet with kraken you can buy a
little a little bitcoin
find out for yourself why kraken has
been one of the highest rated places to
buy crypto for the last 10 years
go to kraken.com h3 to learn more or
search for kraken in the app store and
remember kraken they're friends of the
show these guys are awesome we love
kraken uh please support kraken if
you're in the market thank you thank you
this episode is brought to you by hbo
max many of us are plumbing into the
depths of our streaming platform
searching for something new to watch i
know i am constantly looking for an
entertainment fix and if that's true for
you boy do i have a suggestion it's hbo
max
[Music]
first of all
since i got on hbo max
i find myself on there more than any
other app
this is straight up facts
and they do this thing
that is way too good to be true they
have same day movie premieres of the
biggest movies
of 2021
every single month
they've got warner brothers pictures
will be released and available
in your living room the same day
you can watch for free
with the subscription obviously but it's
like no additional charge you go on the
app you can watch the movie it's amazing
i did that with um
what was the director's cut the
schneider director's cut of justice
league which i was hating i watched all
five hours of that boy
and i liked it i loved it
um
here i've got a list of some of the
upcoming stuff suicide squad squad
that's out now super fun honestly really
enjoyed it this one they've got dune
lots of hype for that i'm super stoked
yeah um
no additional cost to watch those when
they come out
they've also got in the heights
a musical event that celebrates the
meaning of home
you can't go wrong with the creator of
hamilton and the director of crazy rich
asians that is quite a roster
space jam is out a new legacy look you
knew you loved the original and now
space jam is back with iconic lebron
james going all out dunk city
with the tune bugs
the toon bugs bunny and this
animated live-action film
these titles and so many more will be
available in theaters and on hbo max for
a limited time and at no extra charge to
subscribers the release dates are
subjects to change so get on it and sign
up for hbo max at
hbom
dot ax slash
h3 podcast and if that link's
a little confusing you can go in the
description
we'll link it there it's hbo
m.a.x h3 podcast love you hbo
using the internet without expressvpn is
like walking your dogs in public without
securing them on a leash
it's mental
most of the time especially with my dogs
they'll they'll go after the first
person they see
killers
most of the time you're probably fine
but what if one day your dog wanders a
bit too far and gets dog-napped by
someone or in my neighborhood coyotes
you know you never say
that's why you need expressvpn every
time you connect to an encrypted network
in cafes hotels airports your online
data is not secured any hacker the same
network can gain access to steal your
personal data i'm talking about
passports financial details etc
it doesn't take much technical knowledge
you know to hack someone all you need
some cheap hardware you know a smart 12
year old could do it and that's why we
need to protect
our flipping data and you know hackers
are selling your information online for
a thousand dollars per pop on the dark
web no not having any of that expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers can't steal your sensitive data
it's super secure it take a hacker with
a super computer over a billion years
to get past expressvpn's encryption no
smart and that ain't no smart 12 year
old getting that
it's easy to use fire up the app and
click one button to get protected bada
boom bada bang and it works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go
guys get expressvpn it's not worth the
risk
you know use your use your devices with
the ease of mind
what i love the most yeah
about expressvpn is the peace of mind to
be able to access any networks and know
my information secure so let's secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com h3 that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot
h3 and you get three extra months for
free
at expressvpn.com
h3 love you
so many americans have experienced
financial hardship in the last year
let's face it upstart can help you
regain your footing and get things back
on track upstart is the fast and easy
way to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment upstart
knows you're more than just your credit
score and it's expanding access to
affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter rate for your loans
and with a five-minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front
hence the name
or upstart kind of
not really
uh get your rate up front for loans
between 1 000 to 50 000
and you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today by going to
upstart.com
h3 that's upstart.com h3 and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application remember guys
that's upstart.com
h3 thank you thank you
[Music]
well guys it's about that time
we've all been looking forward to this
all year long
and there's so much on the line that's
right it's mr verified
who is he
is that mr verified
is that mr
verified it could be him wow
the winner gets the most valuable prize
an email by moi
the real mr verified
sorry uh well i i mean i am literally
verified on all accounts
[Music]
[ __ ]
what what's wrong with what i said i
mean i thought we were picking mr
verified how are you missing well i'm
like you know how the crap like the
queen hands her crown
at like the queen never gives her credit
stop it yes
the winner the previous winner
hands her crown to the new winner
someone backed me up here you're passing
the torch yeah i thought we're talking
about the queen in england i was like
why did you go to queen in england this
is miss universe queen okay you said the
queen
you're ruining my intro
you're ruining my moment dan this is
about me right now
i'm the original
mr
verified and i'll be passing my crown to
one of these
worthy gentlemen
and as i was saying before i was rudely
interrupted by dan
the winner
gets an email from yours truly hi uh so
and so from instagram i know this great
guy you won the contest can you verify
him uh no oh i tried
mr verified cause you can
be
mr verified
thank you thank you thank you thank you
but it's not about me this evening is
all about you guys so without further
ado let's get started
with the event thank you
all right guys welcome to the first uh
portion of mr verified
uh the questions and answers porsche
we're gonna test their intellect they're
wet
and how quick they are on their feet
number one coming up first is
ian
like that
now i just want to talk about here step
up to the marker please thank you so
much now i want to talk about a little
bit about um
right before we went on there was a
little bit of pants drama going on uh
ian's tuxedo pants
are about what looks like five sizes too
big
yep i may have been caught with my pants
down a little bit do you know what's
your theory on why you got the pants way
too big i mean there's a couple of
theories floating around the office that
i may have overheard go ahead
what'd you hear
i just heard somebody you know say
someone might have had the right pants i
don't know zack was
zach clearly has ian's pants and was
refusing to give them not refusing i
said let's switch [ __ ] pants but only
now if we've been waiting
i never refused and they were trying to
fix his crazy waistline i never refused
zach i saw you next to the bathroom and
you go i'm not wearing the big pants
you're the best is that not what you
said you wanted to switch [ __ ] pants
no wait no no answer that question did
you say that i don't remember saying
that now i want to defend zach oh oh
yeah you were there ap i didn't see are
you gonna defend zach i think zach's
being used right now i think he's being
used as a bit
but i think he's wearing his pants why
is ian's pants so big then i don't know
i just began cosign dan said zach's
wearing
well ian's pants
zach coming up to me complaining that
his pants are too small
and coming over to me complaining his
pants are too big i'm like you guys
obviously sweetie really
there's a
are you doing a group right
but you can't tighten it no you can't
tighten it oh you can only loosen it
this is literally maxed out you can't
tighten it you can only loosen it yeah i
can make it looser if that helps
it's really good i'm sagging
well these are fitted custom tuxedos
zach so finish okay sure
they're fitted i mean everyone's looking
pretty sharp to me do we all get
measured by the same person yes
there's a little funny business going on
here i think i think zach's got ian's
pants come out here zach let's take a
look at your pants all right he's coming
let's just weigh in here because
this is important to the mr verified
lore
okay now now those are looking a little
snug on you zach
what do we think what size is that
what's the waist size come out here come
out here you don't know the waist size
they they were like let's suit them like
a like a scuba suit
i mean look at how big his waist is look
at these dudes that's way too big
i could smell nice shot ab why we why
are we showing the shoes
yeah those are too high and you're
taller than than ian this is like
clearly you have his pants do you want
to go switch [ __ ] pants i don't want
to no no i'm kind of
you know what i should have came out
with like just a barrel with like
straps over my shoulder
now let me ask a question let me ask
were the suits set aside with the pants
you know what i mean yeah they were all
painted together and they were labeled
by name it would have it would have been
at the tailor they swapped them so
nothing happened here zach
and ian yes do you guys want to go
switch pants real fast and let's see if
maybe this was what happened let's do a
fat a quick pant swap if we could please
take a short break here for a pant swap
go ahead quickly
okay we've performed the pants swap and
the results is not what anyone expected
except well
they're actually even bigger now right
they're much bigger now eh oh i'm a
little confused you can't button well i
thought i just saw your junk but it was
just a wrinkle so not these pants these
pants won't
these pants won't stay up on me and look
how [ __ ] short they are can we pan
down look how short they are so are
these coming in pretty tight on the
waist no they're big they won't that
does oh oh both
well i mean that's comically big no
you're like this doesn't make sense dude
look at this this doesn't no but okay
the debate
zach just had these on
what are you saying they were staying up
yeah because he has a bigger waist
what's the mystery well he's not here
well apparently he is
thank you zach thank you
i think that in conclusion
i think you did have the right pants in
and uh
the tailor made a little bit of a
calculation there
you want them back are they better oh
come on we don't have time for this [ __ ]
these keep falling down dude
there's no way those are bigger than
these yes they are
no these are bigger
guys can we please just do the show can
i just say that guy i believed in you
for once we were on the same side and we
were right all right moving on
we're filming this at 4 50 because i had
massive diarrhea crippling diarrhea and
we had to start super late so we are um
trying to push through here guys
crippling diarrhea okay thank you
all right behind you again or what okay
nope you you're okay here we go ian step
up to the marker please
okay miss
ian
you have one minute can you put on a one
minute timer here
one minute to answer each question
uninterrupted
got it
like speed like jeopardy or not yeah
family feud speed round it's hot in here
guys
i'm sorry
was that your answer to some kind of you
want me to slam them out all right here
we go you ready dan we got one minute
okay
okay your first question are you ready
what
is
time you have one minute
time wait is that my only question
i have a minute to answer time yes
okay okay okay i'm killing time time
well time you know if i get verified
if i get verified time
is is i measure time and the amount of
swipe ups
i can get in my freaking brand deals
selling pots pans
all sorts of [ __ ]
every additional second swipe up baby
cash out cash out baby i'm doing gabe
ah
time time is money guys time is i mean i
have a whole
i have a whole freaking how much time
i have if you want to know my entire
lecture about what is time it's 55 parts
you can get it once i'm verified if you
go to lincoln bio i'll describe to you
my 55 part course time
discussion maximize your growth baby
we going to
somewhere
wow
what an interesting answer unexpected
an unexpected twist on the time or the
question what is time
what is time thanks dude fascinating
have an issue having pants issues
uh okay we have one more question for
you i just got to see these these pants
are so [ __ ] short on me
it's uncomfortable zach i listen i got i
got diarrhea bro we gotta push through
we just don't have the time to stop this
isn't blue check this out this is all
this is all about we're on borrowed time
right now we're on borrowed pants that's
what we're on okay all right
pipe down
just take off the pants if it's
bothering you i mean put on your normal
pants
you know he's like wait that's an option
all right next question
okay
ian
take your time
it's no longer about time and the timer
has not started step up your marker
please
okay
what is gravity
and why
isn't it
up
one minute
i don't need a whole minute you want to
know about gravity look at my pants
every second pulled to the floor why i
don't know
the taylor knows about gravity expert
theory of relativity is
moving strong
in me
a minute
okay
gravity is gravity and why
isn't it up
gravity
oh why isn't it up
hello
but it's not in the right spot
um
how much time i got
i could do more why isn't it up
gravity
please answer the question
um it's up because it's up because it's
up because it's stuck
lyrics by cardi b
please answer the question what is
gravity she said it that's what it's up
because it's stuck dude check the lyrics
lyric genius all right
i would say another interesting response
from young ian
a little bit of an invasive answer i'll
say but uh an answer nonetheless he
filled his his time well ian
any final uh plea okay
hey don't look over here i mean you kind
of caught me back i mean i kind of got
don't have a choice when you flash me
like that
and he's parting a message for the
voters
um if you guys vote for me
give me that blue check here i might be
able to get some clothes that fit
and um that'd be big that'd be big for
me all right thank you ian
thank you thank you up next
thank you wow
tremendous uh responses from ian up next
we have none other
than the wizard
the ep
the great executive producer himself
[Applause]
up next we have none other
then dan step up to the plate here
please dan
looking sharp looking great you see that
last guy you look like [ __ ] [ __ ]
yours actually fits great so i don't
want to shout out dan how are you
feeling um
how are you feeling about getting
questions are you feeling good are you
feeling confident uh get us into your
state of mind please well as you know i
have no interest in being here um i
think this entire competition is a sham
and a waste of time
um other than that i feel great though
well you did say about the ethereum we
sold and you happily took the five
ethereum so
i think you would happily take a blue
check mark if it came your way
i guess we'll find out
well if you win it's a big f that's a
big okay back to follow not gonna lie
all right well if you would please
answer these questions and try to stay
on point if you could
as well step up step up to your mark
please first questions coming to you we
have one minute on the clock back there
we got a okay
why don't two wrongs
make a right dan you have one minute
why don't two wrongs
make a right that's a good question
because as everybody knows uh in
mathematics
uh when you multiply two negatives it
actually converts into a positive um but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about morality here and we're
talking support
i'm saying that it doesn't translate
no it does not translate at all um it's
not really even relevant to the question
that was posed
it just kind of was the first place that
my mind went
and i mean there's a
you could you could see how there's a
parallel there negative
the word negative
sort of
you know implies a wrong and then a
right you could please answer a positive
number um why don't two wrongs
make
a right 10 seconds um
that went fast um that went way faster
than ian yeah uh um i i guess i don't
have an answer okay
we have our first ever
i'm out i do not know all right dan how
do you think that went for you though it
was okay yeah yeah i feel like going
with the mathematics but then it kind of
just took you in the wrong direction
yeah i mean you you push back on it a
little bit and i i folded immediately
right yes that's true that is what
happens i have nothing i have nothing
after that well
i'll say compared to ian's you sounding
pretty smart okay thank you
no i like people with peace of mind
all right you ready for your next
question i am i'm ready
all righty dan you have one minute when
i'm done completing the question
what comes first
the chicken or the egg and why go ahead
um it's an age-old question it's one
that's been asked many times of many
people far smarter than i however
they've never given the correct answer
the correct answer is that the um
the egg came first
all right would you like to support that
know how much time i got left
uh you got 45 seconds so can i bank that
for the next question or something
absolutely not oh and why and why was it
crucial second part listen because in
evolution you know uh
these things happen in uh over long
long stretches of time and
when the first you know mutation into
something that could be qualified as a
chicken occurred that being was born in
an egg therefore the egg was laid and
then out hatched some sort of mutated
creature that we now call a chicken so
clearly the eggplant is obvious i mean
if you really just think about it for
even two seconds it's not even a
difficult question egg
fantastic amount of time and time yeah
fantastic so i nailed that one i think
he did pretty good i mean uh passionate
um well conveyed thank you
well dan thanks for uh your answers i
appreciate that and um
and uh i wish you all the best in the
competition is there any final
remark for the voters out there
yeah don't don't vote for me alrighty do
not vote for me there you heard it from
dan himself thank you
thank you i'm serious
thank you
i feel like he's doing a little bit of a
reverse psychology there
dan is secretly hoping to win up next
we've got zachary zach the sound lad
he's coming up next the sound
by
master of destruction and despair
the shredder
the cameo king
zach
oh thank you very much that was a very
kind introduction we are absolutely oh
very gentlemanly today unlike the others
demeanors you actually care about this
contest
zach i have some questions for you are
you feeling confident today very yes
feeling good
and how are you feeling about the
competition are you feeling about your
competitors
um i love these guys you do i really do
so you know it's all good fun what we're
doing spoken like a real mr verified
big man i'm going to toss you some
questions you have one minute to answer
each question step up to your uh plate
there please
um one minute on the clock are we ready
zach yes
where does the future go
once we've experienced it one minute
this is a very um
very deep question because i feel like
it's definitely open for interpretation
the future goes i believe in your heart
you know you have fond memories and
um
you know you have a lot of love in your
life so it goes to the heart you know
you experience things
past present future whatever it may be i
don't think we should call it the future
i think we should call it the everything
the theory of everything
interesting so
i think it goes to your heart your soul
thus the future ascending into your own
being
making you
more than just a person
more than just a human
and everything we are all everything
aren't we we're all everything one is
one two is two
three might even be four
but i just wanna say that ethan we're
all everything and that's where the
future goes you got five seconds just
wanna say that i'm done
five seconds i'm done thank you thank
you for that question
well you know what i'll say a very um
cerebral response uh thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you you know you had me very much
in the beginning you kind of went off
track a little bit at the end last month
okay but i appreciate the f oh laughter
that's not appropriate
i mean at least he answered the question
dan
all right
very good i like where this is going
thank you how do you feel about that
answer i uh it was from the heart it was
from the heart everything is everything
one is one you said maybe three is four
do you want to unpack that well i feel
like we live in a society where things
could change you know things that are
are uh we live in a society you live in
a society interesting and you are joker
brand right yes okay interesting all
right
very good
all right next question one minute zack
you know the rules
why do bad things happen
to good people one minute
why do bad things happen to good people
i feel like this is another similar
question as like the one before where
it's left open for interpretation
maybe i'm just stating the obvious but i
feel like the universe has to level out
in a way you know i've lost the
you know a lot of people i've looked up
to this year and yeah they were good
people but
like sinatra said that's life
you know that's
that's life
that's frank sinatra let's debate that
after the uh times expired it's frank
sinatra that's life
and you know what dan i'm doing this my
way so thank you very much there you go
very good
so i do
things happen to good people i like i i
like i said i feel like the universe has
to level out in a way level out the
playing field
interesting you know we're all human
we're all here for uh a short amount of
time so people put good in the world and
you know unfortunately they have to pass
away but
that's that it's not like thanos
thank you very much
kind of an interesting equality of
outcome
uh answer there
things must even out and that's why good
bad things happen to good people and
that's life interesting
if you were god and you controlled would
you
make bad things happen to good people in
the effort of evening things
i don't know if i can answer that
question
because
i feel like it'd be hard to be in god's
shoes and make those decisions
interesting
well um you are god
what if god was one of us dan asks have
isn't a place on earth dan
all right zach very very pensive and
serious here during this segment which i
like
um that was your second question so
with that i want to thank you for your
thoughtful serious approach to this
contest on some of these other hacks
thank you very much for having me you
look sharp the pants are looking a
little tight and a little short but we
love that for you i'm a big man what can
i say absolutely the biggest big man big
heart zach
the sound thank you very much thank you
very much
all right
up next
the simp
the sergeant of
symptoms the heartthrob
the man whose name is the first two
letters of the alphabet
a b
thank you thank you applause thank you
um what is going so you want to just uh
talk about your decision to tape your
hands green well last time the comments
made fun of my hands for shaking because
i have a tremor so i had to step up to
the
so this time i have no hands
so so you're hiding so you want to put
your hand up let's see if we can see
you're like uncle jack dude from it's
always sunny
i'm yeah i don't watch the show but i
trust zach i'm uncle jack
all right interesting approach just hide
what you can't uh what you're
embarrassed by exactly good lesson for
the people why is
dan can you uh proceed please
all right leave him alone come on step
stay on the marker please uh
thank you so much i'm gonna have to
deduct points if you stray too far sorry
apologizing how you feeling how are you
i'm feeling good yeah you feel i feel
confident i feel very confident with my
hands
missing i'm good okay no fear today baby
fantastic
all right you know the rules we've got
two questions
one minute for each
please be serious and stay on topic
we love that
one minute on the clock first question
if man developed from monkeys
why are there still monkeys
well being that i was a bio major in
college
i would say it's because of ketogenesis
which is a point in time in which one
species diverges into two others or more
so
right the answer right so okay
which means that we share a common
ancestor
but uh we're different species why are
there still monkeys ab
because joe rogan needs something as a
shtick for his uh thumbnails
why are there still monkeys amy
because aladdin couldn't do it alone and
he needed a boot
abey could you just tell me why is there
both monkeys and human beings on the
earth at one time 27 that's a
contradiction the same reason that
you're still on the earth and there's
still
other animals
different species why are there still
monkeys baby
i explain more to you after if you'd
like
well
seems like you still have some time so
go ahead and that's done all right
well a very scientific factual
explanation from young a b we love that
so you're telling me
here today
and the world at large that the monkey
and the human can exist
together at the same time in harmony
blasphemy
you're gonna burn in hell for eternity
for that [ __ ]
it's okay my grandma told me i'm going
there
[Music]
maybe she's a i mean i don't want to be
rude but maybe she's one of the spiteful
monkeys that uh that didn't revolve all
the way she's
my grandma's dead bro
that doesn't change her she's for what
she was okay
about memories what happens with
memories stays in the heart right well
piece of love to your grandma i was just
trying to make it yeah yeah
your grandma was probably good yeah she
was great
shout out oh you're home
all right how was your how did you feel
about that answer how you feeling
i felt confident in the beginning and as
time went on a little less confident and
then towards the end a little bit sad
sad why sad
my grandma oh absolutely i'm totally
kidding my goodness i'm kidding
turn it on me now
i feel like uh dave i feel like uh
steve harvey mixing up the envelopes
here my grandma's alive and well she's
good i'm just [ __ ] around oh she's
still alive she's good shame on you
you i cannot believe you used her death
for a punchline shame on you shame on me
incredible
amazing
all right here's your last question you
have one minute you know the rules okay
this is the last question of the evening
imagine you're standing beside [ __ ]
tracks in the distance you spot a runway
trolley hurling down the tracks toward
five workers who cannot hear it coming
even if they do spot it they won't be
able to move out of the way in time as
this disaster looms you glance down and
see a lever connected to the tracks you
realize that if you pull the lever the
tram will be diverted down a second set
of tracks away from the five unsuspected
workers however down this side track is
one lone worker
just as oblivious as his colleagues so
would you pull the lever leading to one
death
but saving five
that is a long question
okay
so if i
can you say the last two lines
is this deducted from my time 50 seconds
okay so if i hit the lever it's gonna
hit one person rather than four
you will intervene but in the act murder
one but you can let nature run its
course and let five die
who's the one person
your grandma
i
well um being that i didn't get the
complete question
and i love my grandma i'll save my
grandma
you're willing to kill five men to save
your grandmother's kill fifty you just
killed for a joke i'd kill 100 seconds
ago yes
10 seconds
unless you
were one of those four
then it would be a tough decision
wow sam i believe you actually and
that's time
i i i actually believe you
if you if you if my if you if there was
a train coming
you pulled a lever you had to decide
nana
or ethan
who do you save who do you kill
i mean
be honest
granny don't pay the bills you know hell
no she don't
not like daddy ethan
sorry say it say it
i'd
no no say i'll kill my grandmother you
know you have to say i would kill my
grandmother i will kill
[ __ ] you dan how about that
sound like that we won't we won't we
won't for it we don't want we don't want
nana getting that sound bite
all right guys well well done everybody
thank you a b thank you thank you
guys
next up we have a
a category that cannot be understated
it's important
it's hip
it's uh
it's everything
fashion the guys are coming out in their
hottest outfits that they're wearing
when they're not at work
and we're gonna be judging them based on
that so stay tuned if you would please
welcome everybody to the outfit category
of mr verified the most mac daddy the
slickest outfit for picking up the
honeys or just cruising on a nice sunday
day on the beach whatever it is
your coolest outfit
now
i'm very interested
see these guys pulled together because
i'll be honest a bunch of hooligans back
here
i'm curious how they how they clean up
so our first contestant here is of
course ian the salaried employee
uh everybody put your hands together for
ian
looking pretty good
got some open
heel sandals
red pants
of course a starbucks coffee that's part
of your outfit ian is a starbucks
[Music]
what's that say born again dio christian
dior
oh he's dripping ladies and gentlemen
what brand is the uh shirt there is that
a brand
[Music]
do i talk yeah it's uh usually it's just
the mics in your in your face
yeah it's brands trying to tell market
the shirt is
oh nice
okay little streetwear for you wait
there's there's a uh
a second phase here
what is this walking in the frame
it's a homeless beggar
need some cash please help ian is not
interested
uh uh
wait
he has an idea
he has an idea gave himself a dollar
for the photo for the instagram ladies
and gentlemen that is how it's done yes
yes get a value out of every dollar oh
he takes it back brutal
brutal
okay
another transformation
here we go
oh it's the influencer wings
he can take it with him anywhere
wow
that is stunning usually you have to go
to the wings while with ian the wings
come to you
unbelievable folks
very strong showing
can we get a full look here with the
wings and everything
wow
wow wow pray to your one true god mr
verified
well done well done
very impressive first entry
from ian the influencer and i assume
you're doing a little bit of an audition
for what you would be like as mr
verified as a verified influencer on
instagram
so a little bit
of a sneak peek of what you can expect
from our first annual mr verified
fantastic
wow
wow wow wow
okay well coming up next we've got dan
very exciting so let's go ahead and get
that set up dan come on over
all right everybody put your hands
together for our second candidate and
fashion
spicy hot outfits it's dan the producer
coming out
in what's unfortunately the same color
as our green screen behind us keyed out
completely as a mountain dew
best ladies and gentlemen
you dressed in mountain dew gear on your
saturdays
dan is saying yes oh what's behind
more mountain dew gear ladies and
gentlemen what is going on with all this
mountain dew gear dam
well you were giving me this platform uh
on the show so i decided to get a
sponsor
are you sponsored by mountain dew
all righty we have conflicting uh did
anyone clear that did anyone clear the
you got it you're supposed to click
i texted you about it
you can't bring your own sponsors
[Applause]
yeah because you're on my show you're
using my platform let me have this
all right dan in the mountain dew
um
lots of mountain dew
keyed out
uh once you take off your glasses let's
get a look at that face
okay more glasses you are inside but
if you're on the beach or something it
can get pretty sunny
double wrapped he says
okay you want to get a shot of his shoes
let's see we got
we got the sandals slide-ons with some
socks you know how it is it's comfort
it's utility it's everything you love
and more
damn
alrighty anything else
all right go ahead thank you dan
wow
what is showing here
a little bit confused bringing on his
own sponsors that's a little bit of a
faux pas in my opinion but uh we'll talk
about that after the show
mountain dew i can't even get mountain
dew how'd you get mountain dew
okay
i want some mountain dew money
all right coming up next is zachary
young zach the sound lad
coming in with a hot hot entry
some say he's the heartthrob
some used to say he's a heartthrob
whatever his star heartthrob status is
you know who he is he's zach the sound
lab the legend here rocking it bringing
you the hottest look zach
cowboy boots
always jeans
uh what shirt you got i'm very you got
you got a lot of buttons down there
buddy
some may say one button too low some may
say one button too high
let the other button down let's see what
let's see how low it goes
you're not comfortable with that one
okay okay fair enough he said no to the
button request show off your jack there
jacket led zeppelin
okay
oh giving himself a little spank
he's too sexy gotta kiss himself
all right that is zaf
i'll say in zack's defense here or in
his favor he's actually take i feel like
you actually cruise around in that
outfit unlike these other clowns
and and the boots as well
the get shot of those boots again
those boots are pretty wild
i'm not even gonna lie
it's pretty wild but we love it we love
the gin the ingenuity
and the man is being himself so that is
zach everybody on fashion
give it up round of applause round of
applause
oh these boots weren't made for walking
and he sure isn't walking off stage as
the cue i've given him there he goes
zach
thank you thank you
all right an exciting competition
we've got one more contestant you guys
know a b is coming out
all right guys finally we are here with
a
b
commonly known
dethroning zach
as the heartthrob and unfortunately i
would say those scars have not yet
healed but today they continue to do
battle a b
come center stage and let's see this
outfit
okay okay okay a little marty mcfly a
little uh
you know hip
casual oh my god it's the cosby doll
stitched to his back
what is this look this is high fashion
this is shocking this is the evolution
of streetwear let's give us a spin let's
get a look at that thing
damn you better wear that thing out on i
swear to god i want to see your ass
cruising down hollywood boulevard with
that on i need it
i need a video of it
are you are you committed to doing that
yes whatever you want
and i want i feel like if i win i feel
like there's no way
oh he's maybe souling the jury pool a
little bit
but i feel like there's no way you don't
get a reaction walking around that thing
i mean
that is wild are you is this a marty
mcfly inspired outfit or just
he says no
alrighty
cosby doll okay wow
made me uncomfortable
all right well thank you guys this is
the fashion
uh segment
hope you guys all enjoyed i hope you all
were impressed by these fine young
specimens
and so we will be moving on
to our final portion
up next which of course talent
some people say this is what decides the
competition
we'll find out stay tuned
all right guys our final and some would
say most important category
the talent
uh first up we have young ian that
salary employee here with a nice little
setup i am not going to waste too much
time in i will let you uh why don't you
introduce it and tell us a little bit
about what you're planning here
okay so uh since this is a quest to be
verified and really like the ultimate
symbol of me like fully selling out
i've got a array of
uh stereotypical instagram products here
and i'm going to try and sell them as
fast as i can within 90 seconds so we're
gonna do a bunch of three ads
90 seconds really earn that check so see
how many i can like can clear alrighty
dan let's get 90 seconds on the clock
and uh whenever you're ready ian
begin
all right save when right then all right
three two one go
hey guys uh kim kardashian sent me this
skim box i'm really excited to unbox it
with you guys let's see what she sent
today
oh it's so earthy oh it's so oh my god
look it's so like boring
okay
bang energy we love bang energy if you
need a boost
potent brain and body fuel birthday kick
bash with creatine dang energy
chug it finish it all
if you want that bang energy bucks
pretty good swift
[Applause]
flat tummy tea this is like a laxative
when you guys got a [ __ ] and you don't
know how flat tummy teeth wait for real
what wait it's a laxative teeth alpha
brain
memory in focus what turns up being a
monkey guys slam that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
are those is that mixture approved
you want to take down your local
favorite youtube child predator
i hit sugar bear hair product
competition james charles
all right that's a beautiful
second
shave's body scrub looking fresh
but
all right this is fanny beauty i don't
know what
fetty beauty uh kylie cosmetics we hit
some of this
oh man i'm looking so correct just like
kylie this is what kylie always wanted
booty
amazing now did you finish all the
products you had intended
i don't know what what did the judge say
did i add
it seems like you hit everything what is
this one booty
another laxative this is a laxative yeah
and then and then what was it okay go
ahead
and then okay yeah take go ahead enjoy
it
enjoy it
ian who just had like fatal diarrhea
going for the laxatives ladies and
gentlemen
you've got a little bit of a castaway
vibe going on here
okay so what was that laxative uh powder
you were eating that's so this this is a
flat tummy tea it really just makes you
[ __ ] yeah well
it makes your tummy flap by like
shooting it all out okay we love that i
want some flat tummy yeah i'm working on
my flat tummy right now
well ian i gotta say i'm very impressed
how you feeling are you feeling
confident are you happy with your
performance
good yeah you have a mic but
no it's good it's like
the chipotle nightmare is probably going
to hit me again yeah
okay fantastic all right
yeah i i do wonder if we thank you
um dan can you call up poison uh control
because
i'm just a little bit concerned about
yeah i already i already had them on
standby i'll let them know because alpha
brain and bank energy may be a
fatal combination
sugar bear i didn't know these were in
the budget aren't these pricey
you're pricey right hmm
oh they're vegan wow sister snapped
sorry tata i'm loving these sugar bear
vitamins
all right ian fantastic job that was a
lot of fun
up next you know him you love him it's
damn
up next on the talent feet we have dan
the wizard who i'm sure is going to be
delivering for us some wizardry
today
there was a view today actually alrighty
i'll be delivering a speak
okay and something tells me this is
going to be somewhat of an anti-talent
am i right
well what are you trying to say you know
exactly what i'm saying you're trying to
throw i know you're trying to throw it
but
okay all right guys with further without
further ado
damn
thank you thank you
ladies and gentlemen
there's a specter
haunting the internet
the specter of [ __ ] posting
all the powers of silicon valley have
entered into an unholy alliance to
exercise this specter
zuckerberg and dorsey
bezos and
mods who's with reporters susan
oh oginski
whatever where is the poster in
opposition that has not been decried as
a troll by their opponents in power
where is the opposition that has not
been hurled back
the branding reproach of troll against
the more advanced blue check marks
two things have resulted from this fact
[ __ ] posting is already acknowledged by
the entire tech industry
and powers that be
itself a power yo
it is high time that [ __ ] posters should
openly in the face of the whole world
post their views their trolls their low
brow humor and meet this nursery tale of
the specter of ship posting with a
manifesto of [ __ ] posting itself
and to that end my dear viewers i
implore you
cast not your vote for me for it would
be wasted
should by some unfortunate circumstance
the blue check mark fall upon my account
you have my word that i will do
everything in my power to anger the mods
enough that they revoke such a vile
brand seared upon my flesh that is my
promise
nay my oath that i take before all of
you today
to this end i reject the false premise
that one's value and agency on the
internet may be bequeathed by a silicon
valley employee like some sort of lordly
king of old no we have long since past
movement the need for kings and in that
same sense we must accept that if we
have long moved past the need for such
false merits bestowed by some blue
checky
i call upon all verified unverified
posters of the world
rise up
rise up and cast down the blue checkies
what did i do
from their delicate glass thrones thank
you
good night
[Music]
and good luck
wow riveting
with even a eat the rich moment at the
end there pointing me out
i mean what the hell did i do to deserve
that
wow who could have who could have
possibly guessed that we would be
delivered an anti-speech from dan who's
both rejecting but also kind of begging
for votes
so your pledge is that if you win the
verified checky you will be on a quest
to to lose it as soon as post on a post
on on my instagram you can post okay
you're yeah you'll possibly
you'll post a dick
is that your plan
day one
okay interesting
interesting
okay
i mean that's a pretty good selling
point i will definitely lose that that's
a good selling proposition
dan
speechless so what was your skill
exactly
or
oration your speaker
okay
all right
not bad
go ahead thank you damn yeah that was
riveting powerful
a little bit of a
working-class moment
eat the rich eh
tell me how you really feel about me
all right well
how you feeling you want to come out and
kind of debrief a little bit
how how do you feel about how your
speech went it kind of undercuts the
whole like mic drop moment if i come
back well you know that's that's the
idea was like walk off exactly
but here i am yeah you're back yeah so
how do you feel
uh i mean i wish i could have memorized
it but i i wrote it that's a lot of
minutes before we started uh recording
today so
yeah that's a lot to memorize that's
okay
but you feeling good you felt like it
was delivered well you're feeling
confident that people are gonna vote
there's always room for an improvement
well man no i'm not confident that
people are gonna vote for me don't vote
for me
all right thank you dan thank you dan
the wizard everybody
fantastic showing his talents of oration
[Applause]
well up next we've got um i believe zach
young zach let me guess we're gonna be
having an old guitar woo
am i right yes sir all right let's bring
out zach let's get him ready all righty
up next we have young
zach the shredder he's got his guitar
out here he's looking slick how you
feeling good feeling very good what's
this guitar you got is this a special
guitar a special guitar this is an eddie
van halen wolfgang model god rest his
soul
uh it's in mystic purple and
his name is panama oh this is panama
like the canal
okay there you go
uh i think the canal is uh
you know
come on dan
make us all look better here shout out
to ian who's actually having a nice puke
after chugging a ton of laxatives
yeah i'm impressed but um
is he back oh there you are how you
feeling dan you want to chime in
not at the moment oh my god the audio is
blasted out
are you regretting your decision to or
are you happy
talk to me
um
you know anything to sell out
i'll do it how's your stomach feel
uh it's not great not great not great a
rough day for me in ian
rough week specifically for ian
you have any well wishes for ian your
competitor
that was some legend [ __ ] dude so i just
i tip my hat to you man you know you
know the the one thing that would
probably make me feel way better would
be a slamming song from zach wow
all right well you heard it here
you got a shout out from the man on
death's bet on the death bed here he's
got one request left
a shred from zach so with that being
said take it away zack
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
wow wow zach you said that's a van halen
guitar but i i think you actually dug up
his grave and did some spells with his
corpse there
what do you think i appreciate that he's
one of my uh idols did you desecrate his
grave no no okay just making sure
wow wow wow so tell me about what you
just performed was that all improvised
was that a planned set is that your
original song tell me about it it's an
original song it's called i feel you
um
majority was improvised played a little
melody um yeah it's original i feel you
well i feel you i'm feeling you wow wow
wow put your hands together
how you feeling how'd that go still on
top of the world right now
wow wow zacky who knew exactly well we
all knew zach could shred did you all
know
fantastic well
very nice
very very nice
hey come on of course zach thank you
this was all this whole thing by the way
was just a giant
uh roo basically this was your idea
right this segment
this was all just all this was it we all
you know how like you throw a whole
party just so like you get the one girl
you like to come over to your house but
you don't care about the party
that was like this for
this whole competition right i wouldn't
put it that way i feel like this kind of
transpired into a
loving fun right right that's true just
a little comedy by yours truly
all right thank you zach
fantastic great work wow the man can
shred what can you say
how long you been playing guitar since
i've been four years old since four
wow who taught you to play for so i took
a few lessons had a few cool guitar
teachers but majority was self-taught
fascinating you you learn like scales
and all that stuff you've studied the
arts scales and you learn the majority
of the stuff being on playing shows and
kind of when things go wrong that's when
you have to adapt and
you know figure out how different things
work just like life itself hey [ __ ]
people hey everybody you ever smashed a
guitar
no let's do it right here right now oh
okay all right
no good how much that guitar set you
back
about two two g's um
come on let's smash it
all right thank you zack
take about what a guy what a performance
the legendary
zack the sound lad
well
i believe we have uh one final
contestant is that right
a b
coming at you
this is your [ __ ] this is your last
chance
ladies and gentlemen we'll be right back
with a b
finally
we have a b
the magician today with a little bit of
a surprise here first what have you got
here uh for us today ab well i'm not as
talented as zach but i do have something
here that i want to show to everyone the
audience took a story in my past that
was very cringy and today i want to turn
that around what i have here today
wow
the cursed bongos set
for those of you that may have missed
the story uh a b told of well why don't
you give us a reader's digest real quick
for the people that missed it really
quick uh yeah so one time when i was
younger i got really high a girl came
over and right when she was outside she
texted me and said listen we're just
friends don't try anything i'm a
respectful king i didn't try anything
so i all i had to do at the house
because i had no cable was play
the game donkey kong or donkey kong
jungle beat
and uh had a very awkward interaction
and in this game you play you clap for
some reason i was really high i clap and
i look at the girl she was staring at me
and it was a [ __ ] nightmare but today
so so hold on let's not lost over that
too much you would hit the drum
right and then you would look and stare
at her well you you have to clap so i
play clap i look at her and i saw her
like kind of staring me down and you
kept playing i'm nervous and i start
playing a little harder
and yeah
and then what did she say to you when
she left
she said you're such a little [ __ ]
right
it's haunted me i'm still still
decrypting that uh still living
those words echo in the mind yes this is
for the uh foot soldiers i know they
really want okay they wanted to see so
so um without further ado
donkey kong
jungle beats
a b
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're such a little [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
incredible
how are you excuse me thank you olivia
uh a.b how are you feeling
sit on the couch with him oh let's have
a let's have a chat here like a little
debrief there
reliving some uh traumatic memories
there you want to talk about it
well i
i don't know why just in this moment i
just thought about if the girl watches
this episode
and i really hope she doesn't
but what are you afraid of if she does
see it
i
i cause like now it's became a meme and
like a happy memory thanks to the
soldiers but if she contacts me in any
way
i'm afraid i bad memories are going to
take over again interesting so you you
want to hold on to the purity of that
memory well i assure you if she was
going to see it she already
she already did right
and and and how was it so can you tell
me what is the talent that you're
exhibiting here today
uh
tenacity
and what and how is that
because i keep moving forward
you keep moving forward moving forward
through adversity through sunshine and
rain and cringe
this this was a really harrowing moment
in your life and you've moved past it
you've overcome it i've overcome it yes
thanks to uh thanks to you thanks
everybody here thanks everyone in the
audience thank you all
so so overcoming is the talent exhibited
here today for maybe
can you show me i wanna i'm actually
just curious about how this game works
yeah so while we were
just shooting that when she was looking
at like when olivia was looking at me
right now who believe he's a sweetheart
i was fine with the whole idea but
honestly when she was looking at me i
started freaking out like i did back
then and if you'll notice i'm sure
someone can rewatch the gameplay i
immediately started [ __ ] up in the
game so um yeah i just want to point it
out you want to do it can i pretend to
be the girl let's kick it up a notch
here maybe
go ahead let's just let's go ahead let's
relive it
okay so what is the clapping they can
censor clapping
there's a little speaker on it
[Music]
there's a little speaker on it can sense
what i'm clapping and the clap is
usually to get over like an obstacle or
to punch an enemy
okay so interesting so we we drum to
move
yep and two drums to jump
two uh both to jump so like right there
and then see the enemies as with a
little clap
i can see why this didn't really catch
on
yeah um it's very awkward for like first
time a girl comes over
uh but besides that it's a lot of fun
it's a lot of fun
it reminds me when those hardcore gamers
may play like dark souls with like uh a
bowl of spaghetti or whatever crazy
stuff they dream of
yes all right so play and then look over
to me as i judge you okay
[Music]
very uncomfortable when he's when he
stares at me for sure
and in this moment i wonder
what was it you were expecting of her
when you when you looked over at her
what was it you're expecting like i was
just in survival mode i just wanted it
to end why did you keep looking at her
because i don't know when you're high
you like
like stuff triggers you to remember i
don't know like sounds i don't know i
wouldn't realize i would be in the game
i had to play it give me some more looks
because it is okay so i'd be immersed
and yeah when i slept
i'm like checking on her
in like five minutes
okay oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] my life why hasn't she left here
why hasn't she played
right did you ask if she wanted to play
yes and what did she say
she said i don't play normal video games
why would i want to play this
that's a pretty good answer
yeah this is some wild [ __ ]
which if you think about it was her
being like why like let's move on let's
not play this game anymore
yeah but i mean i didn't have a lot of
stuff at my place at the time and i mean
i didn't there's not a lot to do there's
no cable
there's no food in the fridge i don't
think i think there's there was nothing
there's nothing right lebanese
sandwiches and dk
fantastic well you really have overcome
a lot haven't you
wow thank you a b for sharing what a
what a journey he's been through i mean
really wow
rock bottom
yep don't play
i do actually
but i don't know if now is the time
probably not yeah okay well guys let's
let's go back to the table and kind of
summarize and then we will take a vote
on who is going to be our 2021
mr verified
thank you thank you
okay guys i hope you enjoyed the first
ever
mr verified i had a lot of fun
thank you to our contestants they really
put themselves out there gave it their
best except for dan of course who's been
trying to throw it but uh he also wants
to win let's be very clear about that
nope
untrue
false
enactment we'll see we'll see
regardless
um to cast your vote
it's going to be linked in the
description
below so you'll be able to click cast
your vote there
the votes will be entirely anonymous
nobody will have access to that none of
us and we will reveal the winner on
friday during after dark where you guys
will also be able to cast your votes
there before we um
before we announce the winner but boy
this is
this is exciting i have to say
and there's so much on the line too i
mean
i can't guarantee that you're gonna get
verified obviously but i can write an
email
i can do that
you know
i can do that i can write an email so a
lot riding
um and uh yeah so
tune in on for friday for the epic
conclusion to that
so i is the deal uh just one platform or
like you know if like a b for example
has a twitter account will you do his
instagram and his twitter yeah great
question yes i will write email to every
social media
partner i have i have one for twitter
hey twitter world this is one for
instagram and i
i think i even have one for tick tock
which i know may interest you most of
all maybe
no i am going out there to make one of
you mr bear if bye
yes yes
what about myspace what can you do for
me i don't have connections at myspace
unfortunately i'm back to being on
facebook you got a facebook connect
facebook has blue balled me ever since i
made all those videos
[ __ ] on soflo
since soflo
yeah they've been blueballing me ever
since you know they've been they were
defensive of soflow yeah because i was
calling them out for really shady go
practice like monetizing software who's
literally just uploading people's videos
and you know they allowed soflow if you
guys remember that whole debacle he we
made up this soflo antonio or or yeah so
flow bro so flow broke yeah and they
allowed soflo
someone at facebook granted his request
to take all of the members out of that
group augment it to his own group and
shut it down wow
that's one of the craziest things i've
ever seen a social media platform pull
off you know why i remembered the name
of that facebook page why is that
because i believe that was the first
h3h3 productions video that i ever saw
oh nice how was it i think that was a
good video it made me a fan thank you so
much yeah we went all out for the soul
flow bro i remember
shooting all those videos lots of
editing great one well thank you dan and
look it's brought us together in the end
yeah who would have thought it would
have done i was watching on my laptop in
2015 or whatever the [ __ ] that was thank
you thank you
simp
well
okay all right i'm just retelling
history here you of all people beta
spade huh sam
s-i-m-p
well that's our show for the day i hope
you guys enjoyed
and uh make sure to tune in on friday
who's gonna win it hopefully ethan won't
have diarrhea anymore that is real by
the way those were not jokes ethan
this episode took like 14 hours to shoot
even though it's shorter than normal
because we've been stopping every 10
minutes for ethan to go to the bathroom
yeah i'm sorry guy and and honestly
thank you guys for sticking it out
because it's 7 p.m right now
and uh actually we're not even done yet
but
um thank you guys for sticking it out
because you know i was at this crossroad
around four o'clock
and you know
because we were gonna have to come back
tomorrow and i was thinking like if i'm
really sick i don't think i might even
be able to come in tomorrow yep so thank
you guys for sticking it out today i
appreciate that you got it happy to be
here thank you thank you i have some
footage of you suffering maybe we could
just overlay real quick yeah we
put a camera in the bathroom yeah a
dramatic day and combined with ian
puking several times
there's a lot of bottoms how are you
feeling ian are you feeling any better
i'm uh um
i'm a shell of my former self
how do you feel for real i'm curious
it's not great not great
you feel nauseous still what year is
this
okay all right all right
that man is dedicated take that into
consideration when when casting your
vote the man has dedicated that's true
and i wish you the best
i haven't [ __ ] or pissed anything for
the show ever ian over here puking his
brains out yeah he he
his bodily fluids are
are
spilled regularly
true for this show
all right guys well thank you so much
for watching hope you had as much fun as
we had filming it
we'll see you on friday
you